if you had to battle bloodthirsty
monsters what would you do death is
about to get you and you'll have to
travel around the world and beat three
gruesome mysteries in order to find and
kill the man that stole your Humanity
using human corpse heads as meat Shields
Undead monster flesh and silver bullets
designed to fight werewolves I'm going
to break down the mistakes made what you
should do and how to beat the three
horror Mysteries and Undead murder farce
misplay is a free to use loyalty app for
those of us who love playing mobile
games with tons of mobile games each new
game you play through their program
earns you points toward gift cards for
awesome Brands like Amazon Walmart Visa
Xbox PlayStation and more and the more
you play the more you earn over 60
million in gift cards has already been
redeemed misplay offers a huge catalog
of mobile games across different genres
puzzle word strategy adventure and more
so get in on Gaming's best kep secret
download misplay for free by clicking
the link in the video description or by
visiting misplay do.com slht get 200
bonus free points for signing up today
and use my code htb 50 inside the app to
get an additional 53 points which that
will help you earn towards redeeming
your first gift card use code htb 50 and
download the app for free here so help
your loved ones by going the extra mile
with your gifts through missplay thank
you to misplay for sponsoring the video
now back to the show this monster hunter
has no idea he's about to go on the most
epic adventure involving vampire magic
werewolves and a new type of hybrid
Monster killer that the world has never
seen sugaru it's the new here is the
last of his kind a half a demon half
human Abomination he spends his days
fighting ruthless monsters like him in
bloody MMA death games for Quick Cash
because he needs to find the man that
turned him into this monster before it's
too late the only mysterious clue that
he has to go off of is the man's cane if
he doesn't find his creator soon his
half demon mind will turn him mad one
day he meets a girl creeping on him and
he thinks it's just some hot fan ooh but
doesn't know she's about to change his
entire life the two get into a battle
but sugaru barely defeats her and asks
who the hell she is and he hears her
talking but sees her lips not move and
that's when he discovers something crazy
this terrifying head but she's more than
just a cheap anime knockoff a world
famous detective Aya rindo she and her
Mage Suzuki have come to warn him that
he's running out of time yeah no kidding
she's just like him but a different kind
of monster sugara says that he recently
started feeling like [__] and finds out
it's no coincidence a reveals that his
half demon side is too unstable and will
soon kill him from the inside unless he
finds a cure or buys time she offers him
a deal to temporarily save his life but
doesn't realize she's just as screwed as
he is 6 months ago a man brutally stole
her body and left her for dead since
then she's been tracking him down to get
her body back using only the two Clues
she has to find him he's a foreigner and
K A came with the letter M on it and was
spotted in Japan recently suguru eyes
suddenly pop out and they both realize
they're both looking for the same man he
escaped from his horrifying facility but
is now desperate to go meet his maker in
order to save his life but I warned him
that this journey will cost him as an
mortal monster drinking her spit or
blood can extend Sugar's life
temporarily but if they don't find Mr M
soon she will go and kick the bucket
because she's on the verge of giving up
this means sugaru will have no one to
stop his horrifying death the stak's
high he accepts her offer and they lay
out the game plan and piece together the
clues of their enemy an old Foreigner
with a cane European design with the
letter M on it but tracking this cane
will force them to meet Europe's most
famous real life serial killers within
the next few months and they'll have to
go solve three insane murder mysteries
in them out will help them find their
greatest enemy or die trying tracking
the cane maker to Europe they start
clearing monster mystery cases while
keeping their eyes open and soon get
called on their latest job in a town
where Mr M was spotted 1898 Easter
France the case solve the vampire murder
of this family victim the wife the time
limit to solve this case 24 hours
beloved by the human town they live in
this family doesn't need humans and has
no enemies until now which means anyone
could be guilty they meet the family and
here are the potential suspects pops
goatee outest model son Second Son
blonde short kid Raul and little kid
Charlotte Butler Alfred and the other
human chick servant I reveals her head
for shock factor and they get to work
the father tells them that since vampire
corpses Decay fast he already has buried
his wife but took a picture of the crime
scene and gives them the details 12:00
a.m. the family eats dinner and by 12:30
a.m. dinner ends and family separates
and at 1:00 a.m. the father stops by his
Warehouse to get his gun and goes
hunting doesn't see the murder weapon in
there and at 1:30 a.m. father comes back
and finds a murder weapon been covered
in blood in the warehouse and his wife
dead in her work room where she build
custom furniture as a hooby coming in a
then noticed his real swords hung from
the wall but they're slightly crooked
interesting scanning the photo and crime
scene she spots crazy details a calm
face showing no signs of struggle no
screams or detection the bottom of the
chair soaked in blood confirms she died
here the body covered in holy water and
a silver steak covered in blood that was
found in their locked Warehouse room but
vampires don't keep silver staks in
their house the father says they killed
a vampire hunter 6 months ago and kept
his weapons in the warehouse the killer
must have used that stake as the murder
weapon or so he thinks piecing together
Clues a can tell the killer was strong
enough to stab the mother vampire with a
stake and somehow masked their scent in
order to sneak into the room but certain
Clues don't make sense why were these
two things a coat The Empty Bottle
containing a tiny amount of blood on it
and a fingerprint left behind and why is
the corpse covered in holy water and why
was the murder weapon removed and put
back into the warehouse who would do
that a warns the family that something
about this feels way off humans can't
kill vampires so easily but holding a
silver steak as a vampire would have
left burn marks on their hands that
would take weeks to recover from so she
checks out everybody hands and she
doesn't see anything strange except one
thing suddenly a declares that this case
was an inside job one of these six
vampires is the murderer shocking
everyone here all because of these eight
factors why are there no signs of the
wife waking up before death vampires are
sensitive to sound and smell compared to
humans it's strange why she didn't sense
any attacks and two why did the attacker
choose to sneak at midnight why not the
daytime when the vampires would be
sleeping in week and three why did the
Corbit leave the bottle of holy water at
the crime scene it's not difficult to
take away a bottle from a scene unlike a
coat warrant to cover up blood from
getting on a person and four how did no
one hear the sound and five why did the
Corbat know about the silver steak in
the warehouse somebody must be familiar
with the interior of the castle and six
how could the Corbat know the location
of Hannah's room and exact time she was
napping and seven why did the corporate
pull out the silver steak from the body
and put it back in the warehouse okay
before [__] goes south real quick I'm
going to solve this and other murders
easily without using superpowers by
using our four simple step framework
combining us murder statistics with
human emotion because the answer is
actually so obvious let me explain one I
would first identify the crime scene
area and set up a perimeter around it to
contain important evidence even from the
surrounding rooms and all the pathways
leading to the warehouse because it's
always good to have more evidence to
work with than less two before coming up
with an action plan I'm going to be
looking at whether there were any
threats to the evidence that we should
know so just removing the Dead Mother's
body for example would have messed up
the crime scene a little bit and should
have been addressed before moving on to
our next step three which would be to
conduct a primary and secondary survey
of the crime scene including taking my
own photographs to basically collect and
document as much evidence as I could so
we can recreate it later in a controlled
environment without the annoying family
getting in the way especially if one of
them here is guilty four this would
allow us to finally record and preserve
evidence and quickly piece things
together in a properly documented way
and not just like Sherlock Holmes on the
fly over here which might work for a
bodess head but not for the average
handsome stud like me especially when I
could have told you beforehand that the
family was already guilty here's why
according to these statistics the US in
2022 had over 3,560 murders where the
murderer was at least an acquaintance to
the victim if not closer compared to the
1,998 murders recorded that were done by
complete strangers in relation to the
victim and murderers being closer to
their victims on average is due to the
same reason that your aunt cried during
the ending of Iron Giant because humans
are very emotional beings and often
murder out of impulse unless they're
completely nuts have you ever tried to
kill anyone in real life it's really
hard the vampires here are basically
humans with emotions from the looks of
things and this is why even without
crime statistics or these people being
human in situations like this the murder
would always be someone close to the
family if not the family it's cuz
families get messy but this is why I
here will actually solve the case within
the next 4 minutes check it out ya
carefully listens to the family story
after dinner the mother went to continue
her hobby building furniture with loud
sounds coming from her room at 1:00 a.m.
the loud sounds stopped just as the
father went to pick up his gun and leave
the house she finds out that everyone
has Alis at the time the mother was
murdered but this still doesn't make
sense a States the sound of a steak
stabbing someone's chest would have been
louder than hammering a nail someone
would have heard it and finally
discovers two clues that will put all of
this together one the time of the
victim's death actually happened during
the time the mother was in the middle of
building Furniture between 12:30 to 1:00
a.m. during this time hearing loud
sounds coming from the room would have
been considered normal and since the
Killer is one of them they would know
this and the killer could have easily
made noise without anyone realizing it
and two of this is true it means the
murder weapon left in the warehouse is
actually a decoy but the real weapon is
not what they say the real murder weapon
the holy water found around the mom's
chest but with no murder weapon in the
room it's obvious that the killer used a
steak made from Frozen holy water
collected from the nearby Town's Church
the family regularly goes to there's
easy access right there using the dead
vampire Hunter steak that the family had
access to the killer turned the Frozen
holy water into a pointed Edge weapon
that melted when it came into contact
with the victim getting the mother wet
but now let's go back to the decoy
weapon in order to fake the crime
timeline the killer collected some blood
from the scene imported onto the decoy
steak left in the warehouse just after
the father went into the room at 1:00
a.m. making the father and everyone
think the crime was committed later from
1: to 1:30 when in fact it happened
earlier from 12:30 to 1:00 a.m. I
quickly figures out the new time frame
and finds out that only one family
member was unaccounted for just after
the murder the middle son Rahul shocked
he calls BS and shows his undamaged
hands if silver touched them he would
have had scars on them because silver
takes weeks to heal from but I remembers
what she saw right at the beginning the
Crooked sword hanging on the wall one of
them had been recently used and with it
lays the final nail in this first murder
mystery having only moments to cover his
tracks after the murder Raul caught off
his fingers damaged by the silver with a
steel sword and this allowed him to
regenerate his fingers immediately
covering his tracks that he in fact
murdered his own mother getting found
out W charges at a but sugaru stops him
and he admits he hates his family for
being nice to humans and wanted to start
a war with them and blah blah blah
whatever back to the main story
completing the first case out of three
ya finally tells the father why they're
really here they're looking for an Old
74 to 74y Old European man with an m on
his C but this guy reveals that someone
matching that description did stop by
here recently he didn't give a name but
called himself the professor and invited
him to go to London with him but the
father refused because of his family
giving the gang their next lead Ah
that's one case down and two more to go
the gang heads off to solve their next
mystery London hoping to to finally
catch the professor but they don't
realize they're about to fight a new
type of hybrid Monster killer that the
world has never seen and some new
enemies the team reaches and gets to
their next assignment stop looping the
world's greatest gentleman thief from
stealing the most expensive diamond in
the world to penultimate Diamond but uh
they make a quick stop on their real
Mission finding Professor M and stop by
this famous cane shop and they steal
their customer list until they run into
trouble seeing the list they order sugar
to hand back over the list just as both
sides get stopped and arrested by the
cops for causing trouble in the police
car a kills Time by casually telling
this officer that these two criminals
are actually guilty showing off her
detective skills and the man from
earlier picks up on it and is impressed
they chat and find out that they've both
been hired by the government to stop
loopin tonight what a quinky dink and
they tell the cops to take them to the
future scene of the crime reaching this
Grand Mission it's not the Queen's crib
but a famous explorer philas fog you
know the 80 Days around the world guy
he's scared lopin will come and take his
diamond and then they meet an English
inspector they strad I notices a strange
man on the way in now to realiz realing
this man will be the death of most of
them tonight and now they get a rundown
of the mission their teammates and their
opponents a letter was sent here by
Lupin announcing the exact time and date
where he'll strike between 11: to 11:30
p.m. January 19th and this is who
they're up against the opponent Lupin
and also Eric the Phantom they've come
to steal the penultimate Diamond which
is just a massive 80 karat black diamond
and the safe it's in and is locked in
high Security Vault underground the
English police revealed that they've
brought the entire Scotland Yard Force
plus some help and it fortified the
surrounding area around the mansion and
then this guy Sherlock then tells them
to seal off the water tunnels but the
team gets notified that more help will
arrive tomorrow night to help sending
two agents from Lloyd agency designed to
deal with monsters and creatures that
threaten their customers the fifth agent
appears ryanh Hart and seventh agent
Fatima double darts and agents that hate
all monsters even the good ones they
head down into the Vault and they
actually get told the diamond is
actually synthetic it's not naturally
made and it actually contains a
mysterious poem about wolves on it the
filthy reach owner tells them the story
about the diamond is nothing like anyone
has ever seen before finding it on his
travels in southern Germany it was made
by a rich dwarf tribe that wanted to
take revenge on the werewolves that
slaughtered their Village they made this
diamond as a key to reveal their enemies
the werewolves hiding place for future
generations for so the legend says and
they used their skills to make two
things a gem that will never break and
kept inside is a pure silver safe that
no enemy could touch they finish hearing
the crazy stories and now wait for the
trouble headed their way no one realizes
that Professor M has just spotted his
two favorite lab rats in the world
newspaper revealing where they are and
it's right where he's headed too
meanwhile waiting for Lupin to show up
AA comes up with a crazy plan to stop
him using this legendary Japanese Outlaw
Ishikawa Gan AKA you know Japanese
Robinhood basically but sugaru thinks
she's absolutely crazy that night
everyone is on high alert as the mission
locks down and prepares for lopin to
strike I's team covers above ground
while Sherlock and his team stay inside
the Vault the monster hating agents
Lloyd's agency also arriv to man to keep
watch above ground also near the
entrance I thinks they're acting kind of
suspicious but whatever she focus
focuses on the main job suddenly a huge
explosion is heard near the main
entrance as the area gets news that The
Intruders have stolen some police
uniforms and the bad guys now could be
anywhere okay these guys are doing it
all wrong I would stop Luben by figuring
out his brain chemistry and relying on
one of the first corn films in cinema
history yeah you heard me let me explain
lupan here is known as the Robin Hood of
France judging by his name except
instead of stealing from the rich and
giving to the poor he's giving it to
himself and he's like actually super
rich but his title alone means that he's
not just a random Thief you don't know
about but a famous one and in crime the
more famous someone is the easier it is
to figure out their weaknesses because
it means more eyeballs have been looking
at this person this is why instead of
just randomly preparing for an attack I
would spend some time getting to know
the psyche the brain the mind of Luben
with what we got this would help us
figure out how he would likely strike
the psychology of someone involved in
Theft generally usually comes as a
result of not having something or enough
of something when they were young if
they're naturally envious or have the
simple desire for power and influence
but this type of action can also come
from someone with mental health
disorders or specifically from two
conditions one when serotonin isn't
being produced enough in the brain or
two when the body's hormones responsible
for helping the brain respond to pain
and other stimuli is out of whack now
the chemical makeup of lupin's brain
makes it more likely that doing all of
this stealing excites the [__] out of
this guy especially since the public has
given him a title I mean come on it's
like say if you call Dom the rider the
sexiest douchebag in all of Bangkok you
have no idea how much D would get off on
that and this means that our opponent is
coming to fight us on his home turf this
is why it would change how we protect
this diamond right now I would try to
change the rules of the game by changing
the environment Lupin is forced to steal
in I would try to convince the owner to
completely remove the diamond from the
facility I know is scary and place it
somewhere where no Thief would expect to
find it and here's where my idea comes
in like hiding it within the owner's old
school movie projector that he likely
has in uses to watch 19th century films
late at night for example like Fatima's
coochie coochie dance 1896 I know since
no gentleman Thief would ever bother to
look in such a degraded spot and if they
did their hands would be too busy to
grab any diamonds anyways if you know
what I mean wink wink inside Sherlock
thinks fast and destroys the Vault lock
preventing Lupin from entering from the
front trapping everyone here as well
until the locksmith gets here in the
morning 2 minutes left to 11:00 it's
loopin strike time they brace themselves
and then a second blast is heard from
above it's water erupting from the
breathing tunnel above and quickly
filling the Vault room preventing
Sherlock's team from securing the vault
as they get swept up in the chaos one of
the Lloyd agents Fatima rushes down to
help and blows the vault door bringing
the men and the deathwater trap but they
might as well be screwed because they
find the safe has not been stolen and
with no easy access to it underwater no
one can figure out how Lupin pulled it
off desperate the group focuses on
stopping Lupin from escaping The Island
Mansion and try to seal off the front
doors but the police chief suspiciously
says they should first go warm up
upstairs and regroup Sherlock watches
him like a hawk passing over this bridge
and he realizes something crazy entering
the break room he arrests the police
chief and reveals that he is looping he
noticed his light footsteps when they
first crossed the bridge just now
meaning the police chief's big stomach
is fake Sherlock reveals to Lin that
even though they stole the safe the
diamond actually wasn't in there but he
hid it in the real police chief's jacket
pocket going to unveil it he sees it's
empty just as Lupin pulls a double cross
stealing the diamond last minute he
desperately escapes through the window
running to meet his partner Phantom he
opens the silver safe busting out seeing
a signaling sugaru he comes in swinging
catching her and the safe and the squad
in full I reveal she's been hiding in
there all along Trojan Horse style she
and the diamond owner set this plan up
from the start Lupin declares they will
fight them but Phantom bailes
immediately pissing Lupin off while maid
shizuki goes after him Lupin takes off
his gentleman coat and that's when the
Lloyd agent enters an explosion Rumble
is heard again lubben looks at them this
time in concern and says he didn't cause
that not realizing more people have
entered the Mansion the professor and
the magician man Alister and Carmela and
Jack the Ripper and monster they've just
murdered half the police force back to
Sugar's location meanwhile these three
get into a whole three-way thing wink
wink but they end up deciding to team up
before that for just a real quick second
and stop the true monster hater this guy
the Lloyd agent and sneakily
incapacitate him Sherlock's crew finally
reaches his eyes location and warn them
of new unknown enemies that have come
rushing to check out the situation they
see all the horror and their opponent he
says he isn't running the show but a man
named the professor is shocking ya that
she's so close he fires a blow dart but
sherock notices he's firing his weapon
through his thumbs and they quickly plan
an attack while shizuki is on her own
Journey losing Phantom somehow she runs
into one of the professor's creatures
this vampire Carmela but quickly loses
and is out of the count great meanwhile
ya and Sherlock take on Alistair ya
talks to him to distract him and finding
out the professor has come to steal the
same thing lopin house the penultimate
Diamond because it's the key to finding
his werewolves okay in this case these
guys are thinking way too smarty pants
in order to defeat Alistair here I would
just use Watson as a distraction and I
as a shield of meat let me explain come
on Alistair is a power hungry magician
But ultimately he's not anything crazier
than what we faced before this is why if
I was Sherlock instead of grouping up
with won I would work on splinting up
first this area is basically a museum
which means there would be a ton of
hiding spots to cover as we both work to
close the gap on Alistair from both
sides being that Alistair is just a
normal mag but deadly I would instruct
Watson as he gets closer to begin
throwing heavy items at him to keep him
distracted his weapon being his gloves
means he already has poor aim I wouldn't
be able to accurately take both of us
out if we came from both directions
simultaneously and then from here I
would use I as a temporary sh of meat
because like she's already dead so she
wouldn't mind and then we could use her
to protect ourselves further closing the
Gap and hell I would even throw eyes
head at him and just knock the guy out
once and for all and then we would knock
him out the second time for good their
company is looking to recruit and
combine the best monsters in the world
and that's why he still A's Undead body
he wants her immortal he confirms to a
that her body is at their base but
she'll never reach it alive Sherlock
quickly sneaks up on him and uses his
weapons against him incapacitating him
suddenly another blast occurs from here
Sherlock recognizes who it is Professor
moriarti he's Professor M his arch
nemesis morari is pleasantly surprised
to see a still alive and tells her body
is being used as a sample at his house
oh and uh she can't have it back morari
says he's now back out of retirement
thanks to a new terrifying Apprentice of
his straight from White Chapel a man who
wanted to learn more about transplant
surgery from him and wanted to use that
surgery on himself artificially
combining himself with powers of all the
strongest monsters in the world this
will make Mor AR's research the most
valuable in the world and it reveals
that his student is Jack the Ripper he
is the one who cut A's head off and took
away Sugar's Humanity in order to add to
their powers to their experiments soon
they will create the ultimate monster of
the world with no weaknesses making Jack
the best test subject in the world and
he also has part of A's immortality
Powers making her discover why they're
after the diamond they want to combine
werewolf's too and create the first
Chimera with Jack meanwhile back at
Sugar's location the tough Lloyd agent
escapes and everyone makes a run for the
diamond but that's when they suddenly
spot Mor AR's worst creation Jack the
Ripper ripping this Lloyd agent's hard
out and knocking back the other one and
sugar finds out who Jack is the hard way
however he recognizes sugaru as one of
mar AR's escap test subjects but doesn't
have time to kill him since he now is
the diamond firing a flare in the sky
signaling morari and all to leave they
warn him they will have lots of fun soon
bye-bye defeated Sugar's Group after
find out Lupin and Phantom have also
escaped sneak sneaking out from the
water tunnel below the mansion and the
silver safe is also missing oh and made
shizuki also stumbles back getting her
ass kicked but she's fine and that's
when sugaru tells everyone that he
actually still has the diamond and pick
pocketed Jack earlier before he left
knowing this diamond is the key to
finding werewolves they take a look at
the cryptic poetry Cipher behind it but
I already figured out the diamond
mystery claiming the werewolves are
located somewhere within the forest of
fangs a knows Mor arti will try to reach
this Village before them not realizing
that they need to solve another mystery
before he gets thereo that makes two
Mysteries down and one more to go
heading to Southern Germany they near a
small village fendorf the village of
howling to wait for Mor AR's crew to
strike I gives her team their opponent's
power stats wolves are beasts but
incredibly smart and good at hiding they
can freely transform between three
wolves human wolf and beastman whenever
their body is covered in fur which is
too mod their ability increases and skin
becomes bulletproof the teeth and nail
gets bigger and senses become incredibly
sharp they can chase an enemy to the
ends of the Earth in human form they're
pretty much normal humans but says these
monsters rarely go to human Villages but
that's when they meet one of the Village
locals he recognizes them as the famous
detective group in the news and begs
them to help his town and they get a
rundown of their final case a little
girl has been captured by werewolf and
for the last year every few months one
girl disappears in the middle of the
night always in the middle of the night
and always when it's raining and then
the next day the body is found head and
back are broken chest is torn in half
and her hand was gnawed to the Bone all
of them have been brutally murdered and
the attacks seem personal the bite marks
and all of them are by the same murderer
their latest victim Louise was taken
right before her 13th birthday
disappeared from her room last night but
this time it wasn't raining the
villagers thought the werewolf could be
hiding in the village since they had
this problem 8 years ago when a werewolf
mother and her daughter were discovered
but died trying to escape eyes group
then heads to the crime scene to look
around left window locked right window
locked permanently there's chimney dust
in the room it's a messy room indicating
possibly a strangle blood stains but
none leading to the window but according
to the family nothing in the room is
missing uhhuh they suspect the kidnapper
snuck through here the entrance is too
small for a human but the paws on the
floor aren't big enough to be a werewolf
which means it must have been a beast
man a wolf form in between human and
full-on werewolf being sick since she
was a child there was no way Louise
could have run off by herself
remembering the blood stage she thinks
Luise must have been carried in
something or else there would have been
more blood leading to the window but if
nothing is missing the kidnapper must
have brought his own bag realizing that
this kidnapping wasn't just a random
attack but made to look like it and it
was messy on purpose checking around the
house the parents mention a hunting gun
with some bullets that was stolen a year
ago as well when the first girl was
killed but it makes no sense since
werewolves well they don't need guns
desperate for more clues they head to
the Village Chief who reveals this town
hundreds of years ago used to be overrun
by werewolves the man thinks according
to the legend there is a village hidden
beneath the waterfall nearby where the
werewolves live eyes eyes light up but
the man notices this she tells him
horrifying people are headed this way
and they must find the village before
they do showing him the penultimate
Diamond she knows this is the key but
doesn't know how to use it fi man is
shocked that she has it but strikes a
deal with her if she saves this village
within 2 days he'll tell them how to use
the Black Diamond to find the werewolf
Village so the gang sets off to solve
their final case not realizing that more
new enemies are already in town okay it
is clear from the murder scene that this
latest victim was special let me explain
I'm first going to talk to the parents
since they obviously would have said up
the environment the victim would have
grown up in especially since she was
disabled and would have naturally relied
more on them compared to your average
child and after all the twist and turns
I definitely am not going to trust
anyone yet but one thing here is more
concerning to the rest it's noted the
killer went against their signature way
of killing committing the crime this
time during a day without rain and went
through the trouble of sneaking in
through the chimney when they could have
just barged in through the window this
makes it a problem according to FBI
agent and Behavioral Analyst John
Douglas when serial killers start
committing crimes if something doesn't
go right he's got to perfect the mo he
has to the sudden change in Murder
tactics and extra sneakiness for no
reason suggests this kidnapping was
special different from the rest because
the killer originally had no reason to
change his tactics unless he actually
couldn't wait to kidnap this girl before
the next rainy day this is why we first
dig deep into this girl's backstory and
learn everything starting with the
parents before doing anything else and
I'll split up the team focusing on The
Village's social dynamics with Louise
her parents and their appearance towards
the village because that is likely going
to tell us the backstory of the crime
more than the crime scene itself The
Village Chief says werewolves can
strengthen their bloodlines through
selective breeding each generation
getting stronger than the last and some
wolves are now resistant to Silver and
holy water but according to the legend
soon the king of werewolves will be born
or is already among them the last time
silver didn't work on a werewolf he
knows of was 8 years ago including a
wolf mother and a daughter that were
discovered hiding in the village before
the Spring Festival the missing girl
Louise was the one that discovered them
because the mother werewolf mistook her
for her own kid I finds out to Louis's
parents don't really help around the
house that she is very independent one
year ago she went missing for a day it
was really suspicious but I says she's
nearly figured the case out already
suddenly these two agents blast into the
room causing chaos saying Sherlock LED
them there and say the Lloyd agency are
here to help solve the werewolf case but
they can't kill a since they need her to
solve the missing girl case so the mayor
will now show her the way to get to the
wolf Village so what do they do they
join hces however suddenly one of the
villagers is heard turning into a
werewolf gathering around this woman
Alma admits she is the one who killed
Louis from the village busting out of
the house and running away the team
rushes to go and catch her finding out
silver weapons don't work sugaru gets
bitten and Mage shizuki is lost in the
process falling down this River after
the review of the B mark on sugaru and
confirmed it's the same Mark as the one
on the dead murder victim confirming it
was all here who is guilty the Lord
agents return and confirm they lost
almost tracks a tells the village Chief
they've technically solved the case and
they've had a deal so he reveals how to
get to the werewolf Village using the
diamond within the Sun and some other
mystery shed they figure out his
location meanwhile maid shizuki wakes up
and discovers that she is in where
Village and has been rescued by these
wolf girlss seeing she's a human they
don't trust her and reveal their kind of
started getting murdered recently all
victims killed during rain nights in
their human form which means someone
surprised killed all of them she gets a
rundown of all the victims similar to
the victims in the human Village little
girls but before these kids died they
all get dizzy and Confused before they
got kidnapped the killer has a gun and
is very good at covering their tracks
the wolf girls reach their limits and
tell M shizuki that she needs to leave
taking her out but she gets discovered
with nowhere to go she tells them that
she works for an undead detective who
can help solve their their murder and
she is on her way here right now but
then they hear gunshot nearby rushing to
investigate they see the girl that saved
shizuki in the river Nora she's now the
next victim and it's not raining
realizing shizuki isn't the murderer
they let her help for a second she
thinks the body was moved here since
there isn't much of blood around and she
must have been soaked from somewhere
before being moved here since she is
soaking wet analyzing the tree she spots
a bullet hole it's still warm but only
one shot was heard this confirms Norah
here died somewhere else but no one can
smell anything unable to piece together
the clues the Wolf People lock her up in
the meantime back at Sugar's location
the head into the wolf Village but run
into one of Mor AR's men Victor
Frankenstein separating them from the
Lloyd agents they agree to a temporary
ceasefire until m shizuki is found at
Wolf Village she tells him the location
and hands him the diamond to prove she
isn't lying heading in further they run
into one of the girls who helped shizuki
wolf girl Vera here she recognizes them
as the detectives shizuki told them
about and a says she can help her
handing this pie of clothing to cover
their scent she sneaks them into wolf
Village to see shizuki there she gives a
the rundown of their next case with
little time to solve this one before the
wolves kill shizuki they rush to solve
the final case investigating the area
they spot some blood nearby and discover
a hidden entrance this place is
soundproof and scent proof which means
no werewolves would be able to hear
anything coming from here making it the
perfect murder spot following the trail
they find the murder weapon and realize
I was shot here half inside the pool due
to the blood stain around here and also
discover the victim from the human
Village Louise and then they find
another exit from this tunnel far away
from the werewolf Village and run into
the same human from earlier I uses him
to ask the human parents some more
questions finding out the village
planned to abandon her when she was
younger since she wasn't useful and a
[__] left alone in the woods but that
night she came back by herself and also
exposed the mother and daughter werewolf
pair 80 years ago a realizes Luis was
small but very smart and proved to the
village that she was useful to them by
helping them discover werewolves hiding
within the village a then says they must
go back to her room to investigate the
one big clue luis's bedroom window but
first they go to save shizuki and that's
when the whole werewolf Village hears
another gunshot another werewolf has
been killed the town suspects that it's
shizuki so they go after her trying to
escape they come up with a plan sugaru
takes charge and leads them running into
three members from the Wolf Gang
thinking he's the wolf murderer
defeating all of them he clears the way
for his team but I here discovers that
Lloyd agents have discovered her Village
hearing screams and gunshots while the
Two Towns fight each other a then
instructs shizuki to go help the wolf
girls that helped her while she stays
with a here and wants to dig up Norah's
coffin to check something they split up
shizuki reaches the village and sees her
wolf friends getting bitten by Carmela
who also shows up and they do get out
and she gets bested by car again blah
blah blah not important while the Lloyd
agents fight another monster nearby to
guarder shows up to help Frankenstein
kill this agent and he thanks him and
reveals that I's body is still intact at
a facility base in London how nice after
the team links up and I announces that
she solved the case there's one person
behind this just as the king of the
werewolves shows up so very long story
short due to the werewolves forcing each
generation of girl to breed stronger
werewolves Jet's mother escaped while
pregnant with jet through a secret
tunnel she built and went into the human
Village under a new identity when jet
was born but 8 years ago her and Jet's
werewolf secret was discovered by Louise
and since then was trying to make the
village not kick her out for being a
[__] she proved to them she was
useful by exposing Jet and her mother
the human Town killed the two werewolves
but jet escaped snug back into the wolf
Village through this secret tunnel her
mother made under a new identity Nora
but not relating to her werewolf side
and seeing the women being made to
produce stronger kids she hatched the
plan to make both Villages kill each
other kidnapping human girls so the
humans blame the werewolves and
kidnapping werewolf girls so the
werewolves blame the humans and she also
kidnapped Luise who ended up helping her
cuz the village treated her like [__]
anyways and since then they both look
the same she's pretended to be Louise
for the last year in the human Village
while she plotted her revenge but when
iish showed she changed her plan and
pinned the murders on a werewolf named
Alma who was really just fake Louise who
is actually Norah this whole time since
the B marks on Sugo when this happened
were the same as the original B Marks
this whole time after it was her who
saved shizuki after she fell into the
waterfall Jed reveals she is actually
the king of the werewolves and will now
run away but sugara hiding down here
manages to catch her but a says she's
free to go cuz she realized something
Jed didn't kill those kidnapped werewolf
girls but helped them Escape From The
Wolf Village when they would have been
soon forced to breed and use the human
kidnpped girls as decoys with their
faces ripped off so the werewolves
couldn't tell they were actually human
knowing she's a goodish girl she lets
her go and ya tells them both the
villages will continue to fight but they
did their job and sugara tells them he
found out from Frankenstein where A's
body is and they realized they didn't
really need to solve this third mystery
at all but they did it for this anime
vid so they head off to fight Mor Ari
and end this adventure once and for all
so guys what do you think did you like
the video or didn't you like the video
let us know what you think about it
don't forget to like subscribe and leave
a comment down below and as always don't
forget to check out our how toe playlist